never rat on your friends and always
keep your much if you elevate loyalty
over truth you got a situation like
Barry Bonds personal trainer Greg
Anderson he is initially questioned
about whether he gave steroids are
injected Barry Bonds with steroids he
law he said he never did then when
called before the grand jury he refused
to testify he was held in contempt of
court he was put in jail on multiple
occasions for remaining silent and one
one of those occasions when he was
released from jail all the inmates
gathered around and gave him a standing
ovation well this to me pretty much says
it all loyalty over truth means this is
the code of the prison yard this is the
code of organized crime this is the code
of the Mafia they weren't going to
prosecute use of steroids but they
wanted to nail this guy for distributing
it so Barry Bonds was called before the
grand jury he'd been given immunity the
only thing he could be prosecuted for
was perjury or false statements he took
the oath they then asked him did you use
steroids no were you ever injected with
steroids no he lied repeatedly to the
grand jury why did it take eight years
from the time that Barry Bonds allegedly
lied to the grand jury until he was
actually tried for the case it was
because everyone was lying in that case
it was world-class lying on a massive
scale and all the prosecutors could do
was investigate people for perjury they
couldn't get to the underlying crimes
loyalty loyalty to one's employer
loyalty to a benefactor is a very
powerful countervailing force there must
be some kind of punishment and
accountability in an ancient Rome people
were put to death in medial England they
had their tongues cut out I'm not saying
we need to go to that barbaric extreme
but there must be visible accountability
for breaking the law
you